hey what's up everybody in a very
interesting turn of events we have
discovered that Mark Wahlberg could be
playing a very important and main
character in the DC EU what's
interesting is the way that we found
this out it didn't come from Warner
Brothers from DC from DC films from Rat
Pack entertainment
none of those it came from Instagram and
it came about because of basketball not
sure how many of you follow sports or
basketball if you do you know this
already if you don't don't worry I'll
cut you up LeBron James recently
announced that he signed a four-year one
hundred and fifty three million dollar
contract with the Los Angeles Lakers so
this takes LeBron away from Cleveland
which takes him away from Mark
Wahlberg's team the Boston Celtics if
you follow sports in your sports fan you
know that this takes LeBron away from
the Eastern Conference and if you're not
a sports fan it doesn't matter the only
thing that matters is that Mark Wahlberg
posted a picture of himself flexing on
Instagram and he's congratulating LeBron
James now what the heck does this have
to do with a DC EU you ask well nothing
directly but indirectly we think he's
giving away the fact that he's playing a
major character in the DC EU did you
happen to catch those pictures hanging
under the window
did you happen to catch who those
pictures are of and the symbols that are
on those pictures don't worry I'll zoom
it in for you look a little familiar now
it just so happens that these are all of
the cast members of the Justice League
Batman vs Superman Wonder Woman and
Aquaman so what the heck is going on
here it seems like Mark Wahlberg has
some sort of upcoming role in the DC EU
if this is true that leaves the question
who is he gonna play well all of the
roles for most of the movies are already
filled by now at least all the major
roles but there is one movie that has
been confirmed that has no actors
reported for it yet and that is the
Green Lantern Corps it has been
confirmed that one of the Green
Lantern's will be Hal Jordan could Mark
Wahlberg be plain
Jordan I think it's very possible I'm
not sure how I feel about it but it is
very impossible the other option is do
you notice those three pictures that are
sort of folded in half in the bottom
left there well they have the Batman
symbol on them and this could very well
be intentional these photos being folded
and he could very well be playing a part
in the next Batman movie it's been
rumored that Ben Affleck is done as
Batman but I can still see his picture
there in the upper left so who knows and
the other question is is this a slip-up
by Mark Wahlberg or did he do this
intentionally or did DC do this
intentionally if it was a slip-up
well thanks mark but if it was
intentional interesting way to do it
what do you all think do you think that
this means that Mark Wahlberg will play
some sort of role or main character in
the DCE you do you think it'll be Hal
Jordan or do you think it'll be some
sort of character in Batman or Batman
himself or do you think that this simply
means nothing let me know your thoughts
in the comments below be sure to LIKE
this video and hit that subscribe button
so you can stay up to date with
everything DC Marvel and superhero thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]